foreign
raised the rate again another quarter of
a point
um how many times have they done this
now well they're just not smart
you know because the economy is just
booming so we should definitely do
things to screw it up and slow it down
we can't have that and of course they
want to get all the pain out of the way
before there's a presidential election
so they're getting all this crap out
because people will forget to be mad two
years from now Now's the Time this is
the tenth time it says that they've
raised the rates and all in a process to
slow down inflation that was not caused
by an overheated economy it was caused
by an underheated supply chain caused by
fauci so um so attack the wrong problem
you get the wrong solution yeah you just
should have fired him long before you he
finally got around to quitting and then
you've been better off when you have
math done by the medical community
apparently they're not good at it so
this is how what we get into so anyway
yeah yeah let me try to explain what I'm
rambling about and mumbling about here
so the problems with inflation were
caused by supply chain disruption supply
chain disruption is defined as a
shortage of goods the shortage of goods
anytime there's a shortage of anything
it causes the prices to go up remember
toilet paper and so uh there's a rush on
it and prices go up and people price
gouge and everything else there's a
shortage on oil because you turn the
pipeline off because you have an
electric thing going or whatever it is
you got going a green thing you got
going you turn the pipeline off and you
shut down the supply of gasoline
gasoline prices go up so the bumper the
little sticker on there that says I did
that with Biden yes he did he did not do
the other parts of inflation but they
were caused by simply fouchy because
when you shut down all the factories and
they don't produce stuff you create a
shortage of stuff
and the shortage of stuff causes the
prices to go up oh by the way when you
declare an entire segment of the economy
as non-essential
you're not essential talk about freaking
insulting how would you just like to be
called non-essential how do you recover
from that psychologically you're
non-essential I'm essential but you're
not essential
that's the ultimate in snobbery but
anyway we did do that right yes and uh
so if you're not essential then you
create and then when you want everybody
to come back to work well they go screw
you I'm not essential I'm not coming
back to work but by the way you're
giving me lots of money to stay at home
so I'm not going to come back to work
screw you I'm not going to wait your
tables I'm not going to make your beds
at the hotel and I'm not going to stock
your shelves at Target oh well what if
we paid you 20 an hour instead of ten
dollars an hour oh then I would come
back okay then you came back at Double
the rate almost what you were paid
pre-covered oh by the way that cost of
that loaf of bread has in it the labor
to put the loaf of bread on the Shelf
which is now double because of the
shortage created by quarantine so even
labor was supply chain disrupted all of
that created this artificial inflation
that would have smoothed out on its own
if the freaking fed had stayed out of it
but instead they decide they're going to
slow the economy down because it's white
hot which it's not
it was just going through a burp rat
through a snake trying to get itself
straightened out after the quarantine
created by felchi so now we have a
Federal Reserve that is uh trying to
screw in a Phillips head screwdriver
with a hammer
and they keep wrapping using the wrong
tool
so they're they're trying to ratchet
this interest rate up to calm people
down but people don't seem to be
stopping their spending either we're at
record high Consumer Debt across the
board well they slowed the real estate
market down
that's true uh didn't help a ton it
seems no it's still we still have a
shortage of housing compared to the
supply of buyers but um anyway so bottom
line is
uh the FED is stupid and they're trying
they're trying to get some 1970s and
1980s monetary policy to slow down a
different type of inflation that was not
created by the interest rate environment
and they're trying to use the interest
rate environment so they're literally
using the wrong tool on the economy they
really are using a hammer on a screw and
it's not it doesn't work so this is what
you're dealing with but
hey the anonymous fit toys continues
their parade in Washington so you can
just count on it so we're going to see
rates go up on all types of debt this is
though the Fed rate to be clear is
nothing to do directly to the mortgage
rate okay mortgage rates created by the
bond market
so whatever the bond market does is what
the mortgage rates are going to do the
Fed rate is what banks borrow from other
banks for and so other Banks One bank is
now borrowing from another bank if it
needs some money at a quarter percent
higher so their cost of money is higher
so anything that bank does is going to
be up charged they pass it down to the
consent so they're going to jack up your
your auto rates credit borrowing rates
credit card rates uh personal loan rates
student loans home equity loan rates
anything that that a bank product that's
going into the market now mortgages are
not a bank product mortgages are a bond
market product so they're not directly
tied uh but mortgage rates the the bond
market has kind of followed along with
this particular set of increases so
that's why we have higher mortgage rates
while we've had fed increases so not to
panic but just more General discussed
with the incompetency of what the
economic and competency of what these
people call themselves as leaders and it
doesn't matter if you're Republican or
Grant stupid is just stupid there is
silver lining Dave though interest rates
for savings accounts also will get a
bump which is good for those saving up
for their down payments or their
emergency funds yeah so let me ask you
this okay not life-changing 1980 I'm in
college
rates are
mortgage rates were 17 percent
1980 1981 17 percent
um
and my grandpa and his uh at that time
in his 70s
uh was loving it
because he had CDs and money market
accounts down at the old savings and
loan that were paying 11 percent
wow he had a savings account CD rates 11
percent
he was loving it he thought it was just
fancy because he didn't have any debt
and he wasn't going to go get a mortgage
and he was just cashing in on these high
interest savings accounts so it but my
my question George is is the trade-off
worth it I mean would you do you really
want 11 savings rates
and the trade-off is you got an 18
mortgage rate
um no don't want that not good not good
not healthy for anybody
um sorry that your savings account sucks
at one percent back when we had three
percent mortgage rates but three percent
four percent five percent mortgage rates
because it hurts the economy more than
it helps your bank account just stupid
on steroids and the banks are cleaning
up they're cleaning up when this happens
either way they're making their money
you you can count on the banks making
their money and you can count on the
politicians drawing their paycheck
or if we had those people paid based on
their effectiveness they'd all be at the
in the breadline but um but then who's
gonna pass that because they're not
going to do that well they can't even
pass term limits to send themselves home